let's talk about you finally I mean it's
been 40 minutes should we like you
interview people so there's still a lot
people don't know about you although I
think there's a lot people do but is
there anything left
for me to reveal per se I feel like oh
there was something when we were I was
eating salad with with everyone out
there we had a little bit of a it was a
festive day here at work and so uh Erica
Brown went and got a lot of great food
and laid it all out that does not
usually happen I usually forbid that
kind of thing of course I'm sort of the
Scrooge here I don't like a lot of joy
and oh that's right I want to write a
comment card for whatever restaurant um
they got that from I just have a comment
oh and it was you can say well I just
feel like I
I don't think you need to have sun-dried
tomato pieces be that big yes I agree
with you I would cut each one into
ninths
sprinkle it in yes throughout the salad
not just on top and they only use like a
third it was a um a tubular pasta a
penne I believe with a light cream sauce
and then uh each piece of sun-dried
tomato was a whole sun-dried tomato yeah
vertical slices that were very long yeah
yeah it's you know it's an accent wall
it's not the whole room right exactly
well see here's the thing you thought
there was nothing left you could reveal
you just revealed something about it I'm
helping people you pay attention to the
details you always have yeah God I am
well oh oh because we were talking out
there and I go uh I don't think I have
anything left to reveal of myself and
then y'all were like well how about the
thing you just said I go oh yeah maybe
which is I have a very I feel rational
fear
of getting dementia and masturbating in
public oh that's specific very specific
and then even every once in a while like
every healthy person does
if I do choose to masturbate in a closet
alone with several locks
I I go hold on a second am I do I have
dementia and I'm elderly and I'm in a
wheelchair at like my grandson's butt
Mitzvah right now Bar Mitzvah these are
these are not erotic thoughts if you're
trying to achieve this the orgasmic
state right you can't be thinking about
wait a minute am I an incontinent person
in a wheelchair all I can that's the
only way I can come
no that's crazy me too oh my God's too
old I'm so well done so goddamn old I am
just myself constantly yeah is
it okay though I mean you can get away
with it because you have dementia I mean
it's not okay but it's like oh she's got
dementia yeah but it's definitely not
how you want to be remembered well but I
don't know you know here's what I I
think about this sometimes because I I
may already be suffering from dementia I
don't know that's how I feel very
worried but
um I sometimes you know there's all
these people that say I don't want to be
a burden on my loved ones yeah I want to
be a burden what's the point of having
kids otherwise exactly I've been I've
I've worked hard my my whole life and I
think I've been good to my my my wife
and my children I want to be an amazing
burden a huge burden
yeah or pudding you know just constantly
didn't give a little bell no intercom no
you don't use a cell phone I get a big
Bell
Conan wants his pudding don't you think
you've already kind of been a burden
I mean isn't it like kind of nice at the
end to just be like just put me
somewhere and visit okay I don't know
yeah yeah all right well yeah I I look I
think you're gonna be fine you're as
sharp as ever do you have I have the
thing now where if I can't come up with
a name I immediately think
I I've lost it yeah and then I realized
I was talking to a neurologist just at a
social event and he said no it's just
that we have way too much to remember
now we're genetically engineered to
remember like
140 people's names because that's the
number of people that would live around
your village and then it changed we have
to know like who's the cast of The Love
Boat right but who was the bartender but
who played him okay I mean we know all
those answers I know that that's the sad
thing but don't don't ask me about the
U.S government but
um
that is the sad part I have a counter to
that we have not had to remember a
zillion things we've had to remember we
don't have to remember anything right
now because we have computers in our
pockets right you're right do you know I
don't know my my live-in partner's phone
number I mean the only way if they're
when the grid gets shut down by Russia
or some kind of natural disaster or
whatever
uh we're all gonna have to just hope
someone is at the phone number of our
the house where we grew up at or our
best friend at that time right because
those are the only numbers I know and
it's probably the same for everyone I
have had moments where I have misplaced
my phone I don't know where it is and
I'm out in the world and it's shocking
how little you know in your mind I mean
I think I don't know how to call just
about anybody
you know Sony you've been with me for
like 12 13 years forget your own number
I don't know your number I forget my
number because I just have to you know
you don't need to remember it right
there's an Armenian flag and I punch it
and then I'm saved in your phone yeah
just an Armenian flag yeah so you don't
know any other Armenians I don't even
know your last name oh I just know uh
but it no actually it goes to you or
share it goes to either one of you
um if you had Cher's number and you
didn't give it to me
that's her last name sarkeesian
I can't believe I never knew that see
and now you do have something else to
reveal the next time you're on a podcast
you know Cher's real name you could tell
people you know shares real name
so what do we do how do we I mean uh
you're
you're much younger than I I think uh
you're hitting on all cylinders I really
do you look fantastic your brain is
razor sharp I think you should be
worried about me I'm the one you should
worry about I'm falling apart like an
old tree I'm always what oh you're like
the tree in The Giving Tree now you're
just a stump
and yet still you're like you can use me
as a chair isn't that how it goes I
think so I can't remember it's so sad
right but that's the way to think of me
I'm I'm falling apart but you can use me
as a chair at some point when I'm just a
stump that's funny that you called me a
stump because my mother growing up would
refer to me as a bold stump should say
you're a bold stump and I never knew
what that was I think it's an old Irish
thing like a a stump that was right in
the middle of the
um Farm in Ireland you had to kind of
like pull out of the ground with ropes
and we have like computers in our
pockets I want to know what bold stump
means I've looked it up I've tried I've
even asked Irish people they don't know
what I'm talking about I mean my mother
grew up in the United States as did her
mother and and her you know it's like we
had been around for a while but she was
still saying things like Jesus Mary and
Joseph you're a bold stump don't you be
a bold stump and then I would go to
school and my teachers were wearing
dashikis and it's yeah super cool
liberal you know there's like a Malcolm
X poster on the wall and we're all uh
you know listening to free to be you and
me and everything's groovy and I've just
been growing up in Victorian Ireland for
some reason just outside Boston